born on G5
um
and
yeah I don't really see how white
defends that one
Bishop F3 you know that's seven
yeah we have to start giving stuff up or
yeah I think I'm I'm looking at some
sacrifices here
because because the forks here actually
make it a bit awkward for like maybe
this works yeah three maybe we don't
rush maybe there we have like Rook H2 or
uh now that E6 is defended and also
apparently Rook H2 is playable Rook H2
is what uh the engines appear to
because there's a like but and yeah Gary
meanwhile Peter has just played Queen G3
yeah
everyone plus four propelling himself
first place currently yeah and Gary you
have to say considering what the
position looks like